so I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and I was invited in with
these fun props like inflated planets to
answer questions your questions about
the universe so bring it on
[Music]
questions from the internet I got one
here from Cain Jackson how many stars
are born per year how many died well
it's about a hundred a year in our
galaxy we've had like a stable amount
for the last several billion years and
where you calculate that is we have
about a hundred billion stars in the
galaxies and universes ten or so billion
years old about a hundred a year maybe
ten and a hundred a year so you got it
next up from Maccabees dude love
questions that begin with dude there's
literally a quark called strangeness
because nobody freaking knows what the
hell it's doing but what is going on
damn I hate physics that's not a
question
we have quarks named up-down bottom top
strange and charmed we don't see them
directly we can't tell you what we can't
show you a photo of them so they're just
placeholder words for them so just like
just get used to that all of quantum
physics transcends our personal life
experience so to describe it we have to
sort of invent words one of them is just
strange that doesn't mean we can't
describe it and know what it how it
behaves in and of itself and with other
quarks so don't put too much meaning in
the word itself it's the idea that
matters
next Jordan is it just a coincidence
the two major hurricanes a spreading
wildfire and now in 8.4 magnitude
earthquake followed the solar eclipse
yes by the way there's solar eclipses
every 18 months or so find something to
happen there and you want to blame it on
the eclipse okay go ahead people did
that for millennia no no what do we have
here a dagger a p.m. if dark energy
makes the universe expand it makes it
might make more or new space can we use
that space to make dark energy
um I I don't know by the way dark energy
is not so much making us expand we were
already expanding it is making the
expanding universe accelerate that's
what's going on evidence shows that dark
energy is not being created in the
expansion of the universe so I think the
answer to this is no but if one day we
could control dark energy in a lab maybe
we might discover interesting properties
in its relationship to dark matter I
don't know to be determined
watch this space next up on Twitter
charles william johnson if the Higgs
boson etc forms an essential part of
reality which it does why can't it be
found in our front room or all around us
there's certain parts of our fundamental
reality that you only gain access to
under certain conditions of pressure and
temperature and energy you don't
experience a proton in your life but
it's a fundamental part of nuclei that
make up the atoms that comprise your
body so just because you don't see it
feel it touch it taste it or smell it
does not mean it does not exist and part
of the entire purpose of why we have
science at all in particular the methods
and tools of science is to decode that
which is true about nature that
otherwise transcends your sensory
perceptions that is what science is you
wouldn't need the tools if our brain
sensory system accurately decoded the
world around us but it doesn't and
that's why science tries to find any way
it can to remove your brain ie R nose
mouth touch from the operation and the
more we can successfully do it the less
bias shows up in the result just get the
human out of it so yeah reality is not
what you perceive it's what the methods
and tools of science reveal next up Wow
across the universe is a musical I don't
know is it I love musicals if it is I'm
embarrassed that I haven't heard of it
but it ought to be seems to me the
universe would be really good
next Marilyn Baker
what is a quantum particle is it like
say a quark where's an electron what
quantum physics is the study of
everything that matters on that scale
electrons quarks neutrons nuclei
themselves atoms themselves molecules
themselves there is no understanding of
what they do without quantum physics
that's how small particles roll in this
world hope that answers your question
within these hundreds of newly confirmed
exoplanets how many are possibly
habitable by the actual scientific
method we have so you look for
exoplanets planets orbiting other stars
some fraction of them are in the
Goldilocks zone not too close if it had
liquid water would evaporate not too far
they haven't had liquid water would
freeze now you can calculate what that
is for any star and so there's a subset
of all the thousands of exoplanets
there's a few hundred that orbit in the
Goldilocks zone life as we know it could
thrive there haven't found life still
looking for life but it could thrive
there by the way there are other sources
of heat sources of heat from tides that
are created from the main planet Jupiter
for example on to its moons so there are
moons of Jupiter Jupiter's way outside
the Goldilocks zone the moons of Jupiter
are kept warm by this sort of
gravitational massaging it's called
tidal heating tid Al tidal heating so
you might have life as we know it on the
moons of planets that have tidally
heated those moons so that opens the net
forecast a much wider net in a search
for life in the universe I'm not sure if
anyone has asked or answered but I'm
curious where was Neil Tyson for the
solar eclipse
hopefully it was a clear sky thank you
for those warm wishes it was a state
secret where I was right up until the
Eclipse I was at deadwood lookout 7,200
feet up in the mountains of Idaho
checking out the total solar it is the
universe expanding into a space bigger
than the universe itself is there a
clear limit to the expansion so yeah
we're expanding but if that's what we
define all of space to be then there's
higher dimensions into which this is
happening in principle you can go
outside of our universe and look down on
it or up to it but then you're in
another dimension so we don't have
access to that dimension so we're stuck
we did dimension
you're given three spatial one time
dimension get over time for just a
couple more whatever a Donnie yell if
aliens exist how do I know I'm not one
well if you visited another planet with
life you'd be an alien to them clearly
you're probably not an alien because you
share all the same organs in the same
place with the same biochemistry and
highly common DNA with the person
sitting across from you and everyone
else walking this earth you have DNA in
common with yeast cells with an apple
with oak trees so that's some of the
best evidence we know that you yourself
are not an alien
Jacob Warren you all believe in quantum
mechanics or a theory of relativity
which one is better you don't have that
choice they each exist and work and make
predictions that are verified they're
both kind of crazy but they apply to
reality now it turns out we already know
the limits of relativity it can't
describe the center of a black hole so
we know relativity will have to be
extended or modified in those extremes
to understand that quantum physics
quantum mechanics it works every single
place we have ever applied it every
single place so in that regard it is the
most successful theory of the universe
that has ever been put forth it could be
possible that in the future quantum
physics will subsume relativity entirely
to get you to those singularities the
center of the black hole and the
beginning of the universe but right now
they both work and we're completely
happy with them last one
naphthalene Twitter so the theory of
relativity the prediction of the effects
gravitational fields in space than peace
I think the rise of science has promoted
greater peace and prosperity in the
world certainly prosperity and often
where there's prosperity there's less of
a need to take your neighbor's stuff if
you look at the era of science and look
at the kinds of wars people fought and
what fraction of people would die in a
war of a culture in spite of even these
aberrations such as the first and second
world war a much smaller fraction of all
humans died in those wars than who died
in tribal wars if you go back thousands
of years
you could lose a third of your men
fighting in a battle just to gain access
to a property that does not happen in
organized war no war is good of course
but it may be that science as a path to
prosperity and health will remove many
of the reasons why we ever had war in
the first place
so a theory of relativity has another
branch physics science in general peace
yeah peace yes so very impressed with
the cosmic curiosity out there keep them
coming and as always keep looking up
guys know about this especially a
thermometer it's a closed system in this
air in here room temperature is
generally cooler than your body
temperature this is why we have to eat
continuously as warm-blooded creatures
to maintain this temperature difference
we're basically 100 degree organisms
right air is 70 degrees so if I warm
this air then
[Music]
cool